- [Instructor] In this video,
we're going to talk about
random sampling, which
we've already talked about
in other videos.
And we're going to compare
what we already know
about simple random sampling to a new type
of random sampling that
we're going to introduce
in this video.
And that is systematic random sampling.
So let's look at an example.
Let's say that there is a
concert that is happening
and we expect approximately 10,000 people
to attend the concert.
And we want to randomly
sample people at the concert.
Maybe we wanna do a study on how do people
get to the concert.
How do people get to the concert?
Do they drive and park? Do
they ride with a friend?
Do they take an Uber
or a cab of some kind?
And so we wanna find a random
sample, ideally without bias,
to survey people.
So there's a couple of
ways you could do it.
You could try to do a
simple random sample.
And that might be a case
of if you could somehow
get the names of all
10,000 people and put them
into a big bowl like this.
And then let's say you
want to sample 100 people.
Let's say you want to sample
approximately 100 people.
You could just mix up all the names
that may be on these little
pieces of paper, 10,000 of them,
and then pull them out and
pull out a random sample
of 100 of them.
That would be a simple random sample.
But you could already
imagine there might be some
logistic difficulties of doing this.
How are you going to get the 10,000 names?
You're gonna write 'em
on a piece of paper.
That's gonna be a you'd
have to really mix 'em good
so it's truly random
who you're picking out.
So are there other ways
of doing a random sample?
And as you can imagine, yes, there are.
And that's where systematic
random sampling is useful.
One way to think about
systematic random sampling
is you're going to randomly
sample a subset of the people
who are maybe walking into the concert.
So let's say people get to
the concert and they start
forming a line to get into the concert.
What you wanna do in
systematic random sampling
is randomly pick your first person.
There's a bunch of ways
that you could do that.
Let's say you have a
random number generator
that'll generate a number from one to 100.
And that's going to be the
first person you survey.
If that random number
generator generates a 37,
then you're going to start
with the 37th person in line.
So you pick that first person
randomly. You survey them.
And remember, our goal is
to sample about 100 people
out of 10,000.
So we wanna roughly sample
one out of every 100 people.
And so what you do there is
once you have that first person
that you're sampling, you then sample
every 100th person after that.
That's called sometimes
the sample interval.
And the reason why 100 people
is because if you sample
every 100th person after
that, you're gonna roughly get
100 people in your sample
out of a total of 10,000.
So this is going to be after 100,
you're going to sample someone else.
And then after another 100, you're going
to sample someone else.
Now, the reason why this
is useful is you could say
okay, that first person was random.
And then every person after that.
It doesn't seem like there'd be any bias
for why they would be the 100th person
after that first person.
You don't wanna just
do the first 100 people
because those might be the early birds,
the people who may be
disproportionately went parking
or planned earlier or had
some bias in some way.
So you do wanna make sure
that you're getting, you know,
both the beginning, the middle,
and the end of the line,
which this thing helps.
Now, we have to be careful.
Even systematic random
sampling is not foolproof.
There's a situation where inadvertently
even this system has bias.
Let's say that this is the arena.
This is a top view of the
arena right over here.
And this is the line of people coming in.
And this is where you are
standing and you are counting
every 100th person.
But maybe, and let's say
there's a tree right over here.
And maybe there's a road. I'm
making this quite elaborate.
So maybe there is a road right over here.
And a lot of people, maybe all
of the people who are walking
or taking a cab are coming
from this direction.
And maybe all of the
people from the parking lot
are coming from this direction.
And maybe you have a police
officer right over here
who is doing crowd control,
who lets 50 people,
50 of these people in, followed
by 50 of these people in.
Well, in that situation,
every 100th, you might end up
just sampling one side or the other.
So you have to make sure
that there isn't some bias
that's being introduced
into this line somehow
that might distort your sample.